françois hollande président
social-démocrate revendiquée a donc
précisé la feuille de route pour la fin
de son quinquennat beaucoup y voient le
début le vrai début du quinquennat temps
les annonces tranche avec un discours
jusque-là dominant à gauche pour réagir
l'ancien ministre de nicolas sarkozy
bruno le maire bonsoir bonsoir aux
maires qui ne s'interdit rien en vue de
la primaire ump en 2007 même nous sommes
là d'abord pour parler évidemment de la
conférence de presse de françois
hollande merci encore une fois d'être
avec nous pour ce rendez-vous de public
sénat avec la fp et dailymotion avec moi
tout à l'heure pour vous interroger
nadège pull jacques et perrine tarneaud
alors est-ce que vous avez le sentiment
comme beaucoup donc je le disais que
cette troisième conférence de presse de
françois hollande marquant en fait le
vrai début de son quinquennat
j'espère surtout que le troisième coup
sera le bon parce que les deux
précédents ont déçu je rappelle que
françois hollande nous avait annoncé la
mise en place d'une boîte à outils en
disant voilà tout est sur la table on va
avancer il s'est rien produit
il nous avait promis la baisse
significative du chômage en 2013
on a eu 100 milles de demandeurs
d'emploi supplémentaires nous avait
promis un choc de simplification n'a pas
une entreprise qui a vu une
simplification dans sa vie quotidienne
donc le discours de françois hollande il
sonne agréablement aux oreilles
moi je dois dire que quand j'entends
parler de politique de l'offre de
soutien aux entreprises de
simplification je suis prêt à soutenir
et à dire oui c'est la bonne direction
pour la france est la seule chose qui
m'intéresse c'est qu'on trouve des
solutions aux problèmes des français
notamment en particulier le chômage dans
un volume en vous et l'ue et vous êtes
prêt à suivre françois hollande
je suis prêt à suivre tout ce qui
permettra réellement
concrètement rapidement de faire baisser
le chômage de masse en france alors vous
diriez que le président a changé on a
changé de président aujourd'hui mais
j'aimerais que ces décisions change et
c'est là dessus que je suis plus
sceptique parce que je vois dans le
discours de françois hollande
un certain nombre d'ambiguïtés on nous
dit par exemple nous allons réduire
massivement la dépense publique puis
d'un autre premier un supplément de 50
milliards supplémentaires
d'un autre côté on nous annonce déjà des
dépenses publiques supplémentaires 50000
emplois aidés supplémentaires première
contradiction c'est là où notre dieu
l'on croit pas à la version l'accordé
chômage est compris l'an prochain sont
de la preuve qu'il ya eu un échec sur le
chômage et que la politique sociale
d'accompagnement des chômeurs ne suffit
pas qu'il faut effectivement une vraie
politique économique différente deuxième
fragilité dans le discours de françois
hollande il nous dit voilà je vais
alléger massivement les charges qui
pèsent sur les salaires petite remarque
au passage c'est ce que nous avions
commencé à faire j'aurais peut-être pu
éviter détruire ce qu'avait fait 10
colas sarkozy
et de poursuivre la même direction
plutôt que de perdre 18 mois dit zuma
perdu dans un quinquennat c'est non
enfin admettons que ce soit la bonne
direction
aucune explication sur la manière dont
on finance ses 36 milliards d'euros de
cotisations familiales d'illizi
je vais supprimer l'impôt économique a
été prononcé un jeune homme bien mais
106 milliards devant les colonisations
famille à 36 milliards d'euros
d'économies sur les prestations
familiales d'un bon courage puis je suis
pas sûr que ce soit forcément la bonne
direction a besoin aussi d'une politique
familiale forte qu'on fasse des
économies
oui qu'on supprime toutes les aides la
politique familiale non trois fois non
on a besoin d'une politique familiale
forte et dans le même temps il nous dit
il n'y aura aucune augmentation d'impôts
sur les ménages donc pas d'augmentation
de la tva donc pas d'augmentation à
cergy dont acte
alors comment on fait où est le tour de
passe passe comment est ce que l'on
arrive à trouver 36 milliards d'euros
supplémentaires sans transférer la
charge sur qui que ce soit là il ya une
explication qui doit être apportée micro
rapidement par le président de la
république parce que vraiment je n'y
crois pas je ne trouve pas ça
convaincant alors enfin troisième pour
les ménages alors pour les langues les
entreprises là il commence tout a
applaudi les critiques simplement parce
que je suis devenu comme saint-thomas
c'est à dire que je ne juge qu aux actes
parce que j'ai été suffisamment déçu par
les précédentes interventions du présent
la république pour demander des
décisions et des actes il faut aller
vite
la crise exige que nous allions
rapidement or quand on écoute
attentivement le présent la république
qui nous annoncent eux un observatoire
des contreparties un conseil de
simplification des assises de fiscalité
à au conseil du financement de la
protection sociale
un conseil stratégique de la dépense
donc on multiplie les comités théodule
je suis pas sûr que ce soit un gage de
rapidité dans la décision
ce sont les trois réserves que j'aimais
sur ce choix fait par le président de la
république des contradictions des
ambiguïtés et la multiplication de
comités qui ne sont pas propices à la
rapidité de la décision
donc vous doutez encore des acm et un
calendrier précis a été fixé qui nous
mène jusqu'à la fin du quinquennat
encore ce que j'ai entendu les décisions
qui sont annoncées vont dans le bon sens
je veux simplement qu'elles soient
suivies d'effets mais françois hollande
je le dis avec beaucoup de gravité n'a
pas le droit
cette fois-ci de décevoir les français
il faut qu'il aille vite
il faut qu'il aille fort il faut qu'il
aille loin sans quoi il n'y aura aucun
effet sur la situation économique des
français aucun effet sur leur situation
personnelle sur ces millions de
personnes qui aujourd'hui cherchent un
emploi
la tente de trouver une place dans la
société et la chine qui en résultera
c'est une colère profonde du peuple
français elle c'est une victoire pour le
medef puisque pierre gattaz comme ses
prédécesseurs d'ailleurs et réclamait de
ne plus financer la branche famille de
la sécu ce que la victoire à l'open pour
le medef pour la cgpme la victoire l'om
pour les français la victoire sera pour
les français le jour où nous passerons
de 10 11 % de taux de chômage en france
qui est une plaie pour la société
française à un taux de chômage de 5,6 ou
au maximum 7 % comme d'autres
partenaires européens restent très bien
le faire notre voisin allemand arrive à
avoir un taux de chômage très faible il
arrive à voir des jeunes qui trouvent
facilement un emploi
la france a tous les atouts toutes les
capacités pour faire la même chose et je
vais vous dire même faire mieux que les
allemands et vous êtes prêt quand même
demain à voter pour ce pacte de
responsabilité
si les ambiguïtés que vous évoquez sont
levés au ciel a escaladé la montagne
avec le chef de l'état comme le dit le
patron du medef
moi je suis prêt à tout faire qui puisse
améliorer la situation des français et
je n'aurai pas de position partisanes je
ne crois pas que dans la situation où
nous sommes on puisse se permettre des
prises de position partisanes très belle
avoue répondait directement chef de
l'état puisqu'il a appelé l'opposition
aussi à participer à ce grand compromis
social jamais proposé depuis des
dizaines d'années at il précisé autre
point important la simplification
toujours
pour faire des économies là des
collectivités locales alors avec des
régions en moins nous dit on et des
départements qui seraient rattachés aux
métropoles est-ce que ça également c'est
une piste que vous soutenez je ne peux
que la soutenir puisque c'est exactement
ce que nous avions commencé à proposer
avec la précédente majorité
mais pourquoi est ce que françois
hollande at il perdu plusieurs mois à
défaire le projet conseiller territorial
qui allaient exactement dans ce sens
pourquoi est ce que dans ma région
la haute normandie je plaide depuis des
années pour la fusion de la haute et la
basse normandie pour avoir une seule
grande région normande et j'y crois
profondément j'aime la normandie je
pense qu'une seule normandie c'est plus
fort sa marque plus c'est plus efficace
qui s'est systématiquement opposé la
majorité socialiste au conseil régional
qui est systématiquement dit non donc je
me réjouis de cette prise de conscience
mais mesurons bien quand même que c'est
un revirement complet dans la politique
constante des socialistes qui ont
multiplié les communautés locales temps
multiplié les échelons locaux et qui
n'ont pas voulu jusqu'à présent réduire
ce nombre d'échelons locaux enfin ça
c'est jay scénaristique de tous les
camps politiques à reconnaissait la
décence dans la bonne direction
corporative on l'aimé la très
franchement on est à l'opposé de ce qui
avait été défendue notamment dans les
régions je cite l'exemple normand mots
pour inciter d'autres par la majorité
sociale donc ça vient d'un virage
simplement qu'ils soient suivies
d'effets et notamment pour les
collectivités locales
allons plus loin que l'on nous donne le
nombre de régions que l'on peut parvenir
je pense que dix ou onze régions ce
serait un bon chiffre
est ce que véritablement françois
hollande va jusqu'à la fusion des
départements et les régions comme à
l'ump nous le proposons je pense que
c'est jusque là qu'il faut aller s'il va
aussi loin
tant mieux mais surtout qui ne s'arrête
pas en chemin il ya des demi mesures
seront pires que tout est ce que
justement il a la majorité nécessaire
pour ne pas s'arrêter au milieu du
chemin selon vous il s'est dit assuré
d'avoir le soutien de sa majorité
présidentielle nous verrons c'est à lui
comme chef de l'état de trouver une
majorité derrière lui je comprends tout
de même qu'il puisse y avoir des
déceptions dans sa majorité
devant le redis manquons
du chef de l'état je rappelle que
françois hollande candidat a été élu sur
un programme révolutionnaire
taxer les riches à 75% politique de la
demande création de soixante mille
emplois publics supplémentaires dans
l'éducation nationale
augmentation massive des impôts sur les
français surtout les français surtout
les impôts
et puis quelques mois après il revient
dit attendez moi je veux une politique
de l'offre
je suis social démocrate donc on va
oublier tout ce que j'ai fait on efface
la tablette et on repart à zéro il ya
coup de quoi perturber sérieusement sa
majorité
jean luc mélenchon appelle d'ailleurs
les élus verts et quitter immédiatement
le gouvernement vous pensez que la
majorité pourra continuer ainsi ce sera
une nouvelle ligne d'horizon
les élus verts a déjà avalé tellement de
couleurs qu une couleuvre de plus je
pense pas que ce soit ça qui les amène à
renoncer à leur poste ministériel
je vous rappelle quand même que le chef
de l'état a précisé que le discours du
bourget restait ça sa référence on se
souvient de ce qu'il avait dit sur la
finance et d'ailleurs il a essayé sur le
négociant jeudi je ne jugerai qu'aux
actes parce que c'est compliqué d'aller
défendre la continuité quand visiblement
il y a rupture c'est compliqué d'aller
expliquer je suis dans la ligne du
discours du bourget alors que
visiblement il est en train d'amorcer un
tournant totalement différent et je
souhaite qu'il poursuive sa
qualification qu'ils aient jusqu'au bout
son chemin de damas pour faire clair il
a vu que il était dans le mur
il a vu que sa politique ne menait nulle
part il a vu qu'il était en situation
d'échec sur le sujet de préoccupation
majeure des français qu'est l'emploi
il accepte de faire un tournant qu'il
aille au bout de ce choix et vous est-ce
qu'on peut légitimement s'interroger sur
les dangers d'une politique qui serait
en fait une super rigueur
ce à quoi peut mener tout ce qui est
annoncé en matière d'économies
budgétaires
bruno le maire moi j'ai jamais compris
je vais vous dire ce débat sur la
rigueur parce que la rigueur c'est
maintenant à la rigueur pour les
français que je rencontre partout dans
mes déplacements c'est maintenant les
salariés les plus modestes qui ont tout
juste le smic et qui sont accablés de
charge d'impôts de taxes d'habitation de
divers prélèvements qui arrivent pas
boucler la fin des mois alors même qu'
ils sont salariés et c'est déjà là
eager pour eux ce qui n'est pas la
rigueur c'est ce qui permet de créer des
emplois et donner une place à chacun la
société française c'est ça qui la vraie
lutte contre la ligue
en tous les cas vous n'êtes pas suivi
bruno le maire sur un point le chef de
l'état a précisé qu'il n'était pas
question de renier les les allocations
qui sont versées aux chômeurs surtout
dans cette période très difficile alors
vous vous prenez des mesures radicales
il y a aussi dans les propositions du
chef de l'état des manques criants
quand on parle de simplification j'ai
rien entendu sur le droit du travail
je n'ai rien entendu sur le contrat de
travail je n'ai rien entendu sur les
seuils sociaux qui touchent les pme qui
empêche les pme de grandir ce qu'andré
des salariés et fait tout pour paris le
havre et caen est à 49 salariés 5 ans
complètement un nom mais ça veut dire
qu'il ya un peu sur votre terrain vous
savez français encore un effort comme le
disait l'écrivain et bien françois
hollande
encore un effort en tous les cas il a
annoncé des initiatives pour faire
converger sur le plan économique et
social la france et l'allemagne
ça c'est un point positif que voulait
souligner je reprends le travail qui
avait été engagé par nicolas sarkozy a
encore et que j'avais moi même mis en
place comme ministre des affaires aux
européennes c'est à dire la convergence
sociale la convergence fiscale avec
l'allemagne
c'est évident que dans une zone euro
nous avons la même monnaie que
l'allemagne a c'est mieux d'avoir un
impôt sur les sociétés qui soit proche
c'est mieux d'avoir un salaire minimum
qui soit proche de signer aujourd'hui
avec la grande coalition allemande
je pense que les fondamentaux allemands
n'ont pas beaucoup bougé avec la grande
coalition contrairement à ce que
j'entends ici ou là les allemands ont
une ligne économique une ligne social
qui reste la même de façon très
inconstante ya les petits ajustements
bien entendu mais c'est une ligne qui
reste constante
alors elle me rapprocher nos modèles
tant mieux à vous écouter malgré les
ambiguïtés que vous soulignez bien plus
quand même se demander si françois
hollande n'a pas coupé l'herbe sous le
pied de l'opposition à
vous l'avez dit vous pouvez pour
certaines mesures avant d'accueillir sur
ce thème là nadège paul jacques bel
agence france presse
les explications de sandra cerqueira si
on ferme les yeux en écoutant le
président on pourrait croire à un leader
de droite
il nous faut produire plus il nous faut
produire mieux
c'est donc sur l'offre qu'il faut agir
sur l'offre
depuis le début de l'année françois
hollande a décidé de surprendre avec son
discours social démocrate voire sociale
libérale moins de charges pour les
entreprises moins de dépense publique et
moins d'impôts
une rupture sémantique loin de la
tradition socialiste avec son pacte de
responsabilité
le président coupe l'herbe sous le pieds
de l'adversaire peut-être stratégie de
françois hollande est cette politique de
l'offre
elle vient empiéter sur les
plates-bandes économique d'une certaine
droite il fragilise aussi la capacité de
l'ump notamment et de la droite
parlementaire en général à proposer
autre chose compliquée pour la droite de
trouver comment riposter
le programme économique de françois
hollande fait penser à celui de l'ump
acté lors d'un séminaire en novembre
dernier et le fait que la droite soit
embarrassé prouve qu'elle n'est pas très
claire elle même dans sa tête et qu'elle
ne sait pas ni ce qu'elle veut ni avec
quel chef c'est le signe l'embarras de
la droite de ses propres difficultés
bien davantage que d'un changement de
cap de françois hollande déstabiliser
enfin l'opposition
voilà qui redonne le sourire aux
socialistes ce qui compte c'est de
redresser le pays si en plus la
politique menée par françois hollande
sème la zizanie à droite crée un malaise
à droite on ne va pas s'en plaindre
voilà l'ump face à un problème
stratégique approuvé dans la foulée du
medef le câble de françois hollande ou
rester dans l'habituel opposition au
risque de paraître caricatural
voilà avec nous nadège peljak de l'
agence france-presse
confirmez-vous
alors viens d'entendre monsieur valley
qui disent ah bah écoutez ici ça sème la
zizanie a droit qu on va pas s'en
plaindre
- vous écoutons je peux eu l'impression
d'une zizanie puisque vous avez dit je
reprends les mots le discours de
monsieur hollande sonne agréablement et
je suis prêt à le soutenir si ça marche
évidemment on n'est pas dans la zizanie
là qu'est ce que vous répondre à
monsieur valises on d'avoir la moindre
brise a dit je vais décevoir monsieur
vallini qui l'approchent un peu
politicienne du sujet moi ça m'intéresse
pas la politicaillerie seule chose qui
m'intéresse c'est les solutions qu'on
apporte aux français nous défendons à
l'ump et je défends depuis plusieurs
années une politique de l'offre la
restauration de la capacité de
production de la france le soutien aux
entreprises qui sont les seuls à pouvoir
créer des emplois notamment nos pme nos
petites entreprises aux artisans nos
commerçants le président république nous
dit je vais avancer dans cette direction
mais soyons cohérents peu de cohérence
en politique ça fera pas de mal à partir
du moment où c'est son cas pousser sa
direction et que c'est ce que défend
l'ump depuis plusieurs semaines
maintenant puisque c'est la ligne qui
est adoptée que c'est la ligne que je
défends personnellement depuis
maintenant plusieurs années
jeudi essayons d'avancer est si présent
dans la public a le courage de prendre
effectivement ses décisions
effectivement la six a mis dans la
situation du pays
je dis tant mieux alors il parle
d'offres le président elle en a pas
d'offre parle de production exactement
comme vous exactement d'ailleurs jean
françois copé qui parle également
d'offres qui parle de production la
france doit devenir un petit producteur
on l'a souvent entendu dire ça
maintenant et comme vous disiez tout à
l'heure michel est ce que vous êtes en
train de vous faire couper l'herbe sous
le pied quel va être votre marge à vous
parce que bon je comprends bien vous
avez envie que hollande régis
commercialement réussi ce que les
socialistes telus
enfin on va pas quand même se raconter
des histoires vous avez vraiment envie
que les socialistes réussisse et vous
alors vous devrez
bien revenir au pouvoir ont dit samedi
le socialiste eux réussissent vous
viendrez pas irait c1 qui resteront nous
sommes pour l'instant dans le discours
pas encore dans les décisions et je
crois que nous avons un certain nombre
de choses a dit françois hollande
la première c'est que les décisions
doivent être en accord avec les paroles
or ce n'est pas le cas il dit par
exemple produire plus et produire mieux
nous avons aujourd'hui vu l'adoption de
la loi sur l'agriculture à l'assemblée
nationale en première lecture qui
précisément ne permet pas de produire à
ce texte parce qu'il ne permet pas de
produire plus ne donne pas justement les
éléments de compétitivité nécessaire à
nos agriculteurs pour produire plus
contradiction si vraiment françois
hollande est cohérent avec lui-même
qu'il dise voilà j'ai fait mon
aggiornamento
bon je retire le texte sur l'agriculture
parce qu'il faut produire plus et
produire vu que ce texte ne permet pas
deuxième chose comme je le rappelais
précédemment il y a des manques dans ce
discours de françois hollande le droit
du travail qui est un point clé pour les
entreprises ne paraît un manque
important dans le discours du président
de la république nous avons besoin d'un
droit du travail plus simple plus souple
pour embaucher au moins une fois ci les
entreprises contraintes sur les
entreprises est jeune et c'est aussi
l'âge adulte responsable
faut quand même rendre grâce au
président hollande c'est ce qu'il a dit
ça fait partie des emplois presse je
n'ai pas entendu parler de droit du
travail de contrat de travail alors que
c'est pour moi un des éléments très oui
mais c'est encore ambigu c'est encore un
peu flou
ça manque encore un peu de précision
nécessaire enfin classer social ça fera
l'objet de discussions
oui mais qu'est ce qui va arriver par un
compromis elle compte sur vous
d'ailleurs au bout j'espère que la
montagne accouchera vraiment de réformes
substantielles et pas d'une souris alors
que si la montagne de cette conférence
de presse
accouche d'une souris c'est à dire de
petites décisions techniques alors que
c'est un vrai changement de modèle
français qu'il faut engager
c'est ça que je défends un changement de
modèle français avec des équilibres qui
soit plus stable avec un vrai soutien
aux entreprises avec une redéfinition de
la place de l'état et du rôle de l'état
avec plus de créations de richesses et
sans doute moindre distribution
la cie aurait vraiment
distribution je n'ai encore rien entendu
de la part du président de la république
mais si déjà il ya un premier pas dans
la bonne direction de tant mieux mais
attention parce que la montagne
n'accouche pas d'une souris parce que la
déception sera cruel chez les français
vous renvoie cet argument d'une certaine
façon françois hollande puisque quand on
lui demande à quelle est la différence
entre nicolas sarkozy et lui il répond
ce qu'il n'a pas fait oui j'ai pas très
bien saisi ce que je voulais dire
françois hollande par là parce que
nicolas sarkozy a fait les choses a fait
avant c'est justement en matière de
salaires etc rien d'où les chiffres de
la détérioration budgétaire économies
attendues discours un peu facile tourner
dans le passé moi ce qui m'intéresse
c'est l'avenir et il en face de la lune
en face de lui une opposition qui a je
crois une réponse constructive quand
j'entends les réactions des uns et des
autres parce qu'ils en face de lui une
opposition qui pense d'abord aux
intérêts de la france et des français
mais ça veut dire aussi à des jeux plus
jacques le pour l'opposition pour la
famille politique à laquelle
j'appartiens l'ump c'est bien la preuve
aussi qu'il faut que nous élargissions
le champ de nos propositions aux
français
il s'agira pas de proposer aux français
uniquement des réformes économiques des
réformes sociales et la réduction des
déficits ce sera totalement insuffisant
alors que ce sera quoi mais la droite
doit aussi parler d'éducation
elle doit aussi expliqué que si nous
voulons vraiment votre politique de
l'offre qui marche il faut aussi que
nous formions mieux nos jeunes il faut
aussi que l'alternance développe que de
la formation les qualifications
augmentent il faut aussi que nous ayons
un système éducatif qui prépare au mieux
nos jeunes à l'emploi il faut que la
droite et les propositions sur sa
conception de la nation son ambition
d'après ce que j'ai compris à la droite
de justement faire ce genre de
proposition à l'envié le conseil
national du 25 jeux qui portera que sur
les questions économiques et sociales
c'est à nous d'ouvrir le champ de nos
propositions pour avoir à proposer aux
français pas simplement des changements
économiques et sociaux
une conception de la nation une idée de
l'éducation et mouscron
si vous étiez au pouvoir eut fériés
européenne une conception aussi de la
démocratie vous savez que cette un thème
sur lequel je me bats de manière un peu
isolé je le reconnais mais les troubles
grossistes petit à petit depuis des mois
et des mois pour que ce changement soit
efficace il faut aussi qu'il y ait un
changement dans notre démocratie il faut
aussi qu'ils aient un changement chez
les politiques
regardez cette défiance totale dont les
français font preuve part de leurs
responsables politiques de la politique
en général
moi je n'ai vu aucune proposition de la
part de françois hollande sur ce sujet
la réforme des institutions
la réduction du nombre de parlementaires
l'obligation des missions des
fonctionnaires quand ils deviennent
député ou sénateur
toutes les propositions que je conduirai
des mois et peut-être qu'elle était une
conférence de presse
il y aura aussi celles prises en compte
la crise démocratique que traverse notre
pays parce qu'il y à crise démocratique
et si on veut vraiment obtenir des
résultats sur le champ économique sur le
champ politique il faut aussi que l'on
réponde à cette crise de la démocratie
française
alors justement on en vient aux grandes
mesures que l'ump elle va soumettre à
son conseil national le 25 janvier pour
l'instant ce sont des mesures
économiques et sociales c'est ce qu'elle
a dit l'ump sont pas un port vous
avancer pas à pas bon alors il ya
notamment la suppression des 35 heures
on en parle depuis longtemps cette
suppression apparemment maintenant ça
devrait se faire enfin si vous arrivez
au pouvoir ce mardi 7 voilà la politique
de monsieur loeb a parfaitement marché
et puis moi enfin on n'en est pas là
alors en tous les cas on imagine mal les
salariés acceptent de travailler prendre
9 heures payées 35
alors qu'est ce que c'est quoi le truc
vous en comprend pas il ya encore là
aussi dans le travail que nous avons à
faire à l'ump c'est un travail
progressif moi je me félicite de ce qui
a été fait autour de jean-françois copé
au cours d'une année séminaire de
travail parce qu'on a progressé et on a
aujourd'hui en matière économique et
sociale
un cap qui je crois rassemble une large
majorité des membres de l'ump
et puis il ya des choses que nous devons
encore tranché moi je ne suis pas
favorable à 39 heures payées 35
c'est important que les salariés soient
bien rémunérés c'est important que le
travail soit bien rémunérés c'est
important que tous ceux qui travaillent
vivent correctement la fin du mois et
c'est une des choses
qui aujourd'hui pose tant de problèmes
en france ceux qui travaillent vivent
parfois moins bien que ceux qui ne
travaillent pas parce que quand vous
partez le matin comme prenez votre
voiture qu'il faut payer l'essence qu'il
faut revenir chez soi qu'il faut payer
la garde d'enfants et qu'au bout du
compte vous gagnez 1200 40 euros par
mois quand vous vous en sortez pas c'est
ça la réalité et il n'est pas normal
n'est pas juste que celui qui travaille
de cette façon puisse vivre moins bien
que celui qui vit des revenus de
redistribution ça c'est la juste chose
mais ma question portait sur comment on
fait fond sur travail est propre
9h09 sans coûter trop cher à l'état
parce que aux entreprises ça veut dire
que on gagne aussi si on travaille 39
eur et puis ça faisait l'objet de débats
entre nous poursuit ses débats je crois
que c'est important si on veut vraiment
avoir un projet de l'ump qui soit
crédible qui soit solide comprennent
aussi un peu de temps on a posé une
première brique avec ce projet
économique sur lequel nous avons un très
large accord
une fois encore je me félicite de
l'esprit dans laquelle s'est construit
il faudra détails et ça il faudra
surtout élargir nos propositions
renouveler notre conception de la
politique renouvelé notre pratique
politique renouvelé notre conception de
la société française regardez la
position que j'ai pris sur le mariage
pour tous je me suis abstenu bien je
tiens cette position car je pense que
c'est important d'adresser ce message à
tous les français que à l'ump certains
considèrent que effectivement il y avait
besoin de protection supplémentaire pour
les couples homosexuels
le texte de loi ne me satisfaisait pas
et ce n'est sa nourrice
satisfaisait pas non plus de claquer la
porte en disant non à tout il faut se re
a évolué sur le sujet simplement que
jean batou cet événement les chiffres
eux-mêmes sur tous les sujets doit être
capable accord d'apporter une offre
totalement nouvelle en c3 un gros
sourire ce nouveau modèle français jamel
domiens dans deux mois on a des
élections municipales ce que vous nous
dites là c'est à l'horizon 2017 mais en
attendant voilà fin mars on a les
municipales vous êtes optimiste paris
marseille marseille on a vu d'ailleurs
comme monsieur gaudin était soutenu par
force ouvrière
c'est un peu original ce qu'est toulouse
donc vous voyez que toutes les lignes
politiques sont en train de voler en
éclats sous nos yeux
nationalement et localement oui mais
avec la question c'est est-ce que vous
êtes optimiste que vous croyez je suis
volontariste je me déplace énormément en
france et je vais voir je vais voir les
candidats et je crois que nous aurons
beaucoup de bonnes surprises dans ce qui
est pour moi l'essentiel les villes
moyennes sur les grandes villes je pense
que nathalie kosciusko morizet gagnera
paris parce que c'est une excellente
candidate et qu'elle créera la surprise
aujourd'hui les challengers mais choquel
mais une bonne campagne elle est
courageuse elle est résolue elle est
déterminée ça portera ses fruits dès
électeurs de paris se laisseront pas
dicter leur victoire dicter leur
candidat et sur les villes moyennes je
vois partout je suis allé à
saint-etienne on a un très bon candidat
alors on peut voir faire perdre votre
camp s'étonnant quand même un énorme
défaut en politique c'est celui de la
cohérence
je défends les mêmes idées depuis des
années en matière économique
j'ai la même conception de la nation
j'ai une conception la société française
qui essayent de s'ouvrir aussi un
certain nombre de différences bien cette
cohérence elle m'amène à penser que
quand on est membre de l'ump
on ne soutient pas un candidat qui a
voté pour françois hollande
françois bayrou a voté pour françois
hollande c'est son choix il est libre je
respecte ce choix mais moi comme membre
de l'ump effectivement
je ne soutiens pas françois bayrou à pau
et j'espère que notre famille politique
mais notre famille politique peut
construire à pau et dans le béarn de
manière générale une autre offre
différente
voila voila c'est une position à
s'isoler sur wii mais maintenant ils ont
échappé au sujet d'alain juppé sur le
noter
nous accueillons j'ai vu aussi que
parfois par exemple sur le réforme
indemnisation du chômage
eh bien on en a marre en compte les gens
vous rejoignent alors une petite
question encore sur françois hollande
est là il n'a pas apporté le soutien de
la france à michel barnier qui est
candidat à la succession de josé manuel
barroso vous trouvez soutien francs vaud
moi j'aurais voulu le soutien france
parce que c'est le barnier est
aujourd'hui le seul en france à pouvoir
devenir président de la commission
européenne
c'est un poste très important pour notre
avenir national et notre avenir européen
moi je soutiens michel barnier je pense
que ça aurait été bien qu' il y ait un
consensus national autour de la personne
de michel barnier comme candidat à la
présidence de la commission européenne à
travers merci nadège perrine tarneaud
arrive maintenant donc avant ça on va
voir quand ma main comment françois
hollande s'est sortie toujours
brièvement et fermement des questions
sur sa vie privée
mounir souci la question brûlait toutes
les lèvres et elle a été posée en
premier la vie privée du président a
ouvert le jeu des questions réponses
le regard sombre françois hollande s'est
prêté à l'exercice
chacun dans sa vie personnelle peut
traverser des épreuves c'est notre cas
ce sont des moments douloureux une
réponse pour évacuer le sujet mais il
est revenu au cours des échanges à
chaque assaut des journalistes le
président répliqué de manière courtoise
mais toujours sèche comme sur cette
question à propos de la santé de valérie
trierweiler
elle se repose et je n'ai pas d'autres
commentaires à faire
accusé par l'opposition d'abaisser la
fonction présidentielle françois
hollande a tenté de ramener le débat sur
la question des libertés liberté de la
vie privée mais aussi liberté de la
presse qu'il refuse de poursuivre mais
mon indignation est totale je dis bien
totale
et là dessus il s'agit d'une question
qui n'est pas personnel pas seulement
personnel même si je suis dans la
responsabilité que vous savez le
président a annoncé le prochain épisode
du feuilleton en précisant qu'il
clarifierait sa situation personnelle
avant son déplacement aux états unis le
mois prochain
tarnos nous à rejoindre son père est
question donc sur cette délicate
question de la vie intime du chef de
l'état à bruno le maire le maire ou bien
de l'entendre françois hollande a refusé
de parler de sa vie privée
vous comprenez sa décision sa position
je pense que c'est bien que cette
conférence de presse est été consacrée
très largement presque exclusivement aux
questions économiques et sociales
n'empêche parce que les français
attendaient des réponses sur ce sujet là
je pense qu'il est nécessaire aussi que
françois hollande fournisse des
explications
donc il a annoncé qu'il fournirait ses
explications dans un autre cadre
ils nous attendent non je crois que
c'est bien de dissocier les deux mais ça
veut dire que l'engagement a été pris
auprès des français d'apporter des
explications nous attendons maintenant à
la mi-février le point de divergence que
j'ai avec lui il sait quand il nous
explique que ce n'est que du ressort de
la vie privée non c'est un impact public
valérie trierweiler est à l'elysée elle
a des collaborateurs
elle est dans des fonctions qui l'amène
à dépendre aussi de biens publics
donc à partir de ce moment là il est
légitime que les français posent des
questions et qu'on leur apporte des
réponses
est ce que vous êtes de ceux qui
remettent en cause aujourd'hui comme l'a
fait par exemple françois rebsamen le
patron des sénateurs socialistes ce
matin
le statut qui n'existe pas réellement en
france de première dame est-ce qu'il
faut supprimer ce que c'est complètement
obsolète suranné la première dame en
france elle n'a pas de statut c'est à
dire que rien n'est défini par les
textes c'est plus une jurisprudence
un comportement un choix que fait le
président de la république moi je dis
que le meilleur choix
c'est que le président la république
soit président de la république et que
sa femme ou sa campagne reste la plus
discrète possible la plus à l'écart de
la vie publique est ce que c'est
possible je pense que c'est possible
j'ai eu le choix qui est fait dans
d'autres grandes démocraties c'est le
cas en allemagne c'est le cas aussi en
grande bretagne où les épouses les
compagnes et compagnons occupe un rôle
beaucoup moins important
il ya quelque chose d'un peu désuet même
je vais vous dire dans cette expression
première dame de france
pour moi il ya pas de première dame de
france toutes les dames de france sont à
égalité
ça veut dire que cette dame la compagnie
la la dépouille du chef de l'état ne
doit même pas voir un bureau des
collaborateurs à l'elysée donc c'est ça
l'idée je ne veux pas vous dit la même
chose que je dis très simplement avec
beaucoup d'humilité parce que j'ai pas
la prétention d'avoir la vérité révélée
sur un sujet aussi sensible
les français élisent un président à un
public qui a une fonction éminente qui
doit leur apporter des réponses sur tous
les sujets fondamentaux de leur vie
quotidienne de leur avenir national
il a une épouse il a une compagne il vit
avec quelqu'un très bien moi je n'aime
pas cette expression de première dame de
france je trouve qu'elle a quelque chose
de désuet
je souhaite qu'elle a quelque chose de
dépassé et qu'elle fait peser sur les
épaules de cette femme une
responsabilité qu'elle n'a pas forcément
choisi
est ce que le chef de l'état en revanche
une vie privée on a entendu françois
hollande lors sa conférence de presse
aujourd'hui s'indigner sur les
révélations sur sa vie privée mais
est-ce que à l'heure des réseaux sociaux
à l'heure de la transparence
le chef de l'état français peut encore
avoir une véritable vie privée est un
peu d'hypocrisie dans cette idée que le
présent la république ils puissent avoir
une vie
brive est clairement défini quand on
était du président de la république
c'est pour un mandat de cinq ans on se
doit aux français
notons malta votre vie de nous à paris
ce moment-là autre vie par définition ne
vous appartient plus longue il a été
léger jeunes ans je vais pas de
reproches de ce type là je dis
simplement parce que même quand même été
imprudent au moment où je dis ça il
voulait priver qui ne regarderait
absolument pas des français pour le
président de la république lui même
ça me paraît difficile qu'on protège
certains aspects de sa vie privée je
pense aux enfants par exemple ils sont
pas concernés n'ont pas fait ce choix
c'est lui seul qui a fait ce choix de
devenir président la république c'est un
choix éminemment respectable mais je ne
vois pas en quoi ces enfants sont les
pousse sa campagne pourraient eux être
directement associés à ce choix c'est ça
pour moi l'aliment vous rêvez distribué
en revanche tous les choix président de
la république s'engage personnellement
il faut avoir une discipline de fer
habitats un peu plus la fonction comme a
pu le dire jean luc mélenchon importe
quel est le niveau de la vie politique
je pense qu'il faut de discipline de fès
avait été même honnête un mode et ce
député
vous avez été soumis vous même à la
tentation de la pipolisation par des
propositions je ne sais pas d'organe de
presse
ou alors vous mettez tout dans la
littérature bruno le maire demandent
toujours vos enfants toujours gelé un
moment où vous dis mais qui vous êtes
c'est quoi votre vie les chemins il ya
des limites à fixer mais c'est très
difficile parce que c'est légitime aussi
que les français dont vous solliciter
les suffrages ou leur disent y voilà je
m'appelle bono le maire j'ai 44 ans je
suis marié depuis maintenant près de
seize ans j'ai quatre garçons voilà
c'est légitime qu'on sache c'est
transparent je n'ai absolument la
verchère définitive de la frontière
devient difficile on met en avant son
épouse sa compagne ou est-ce qu'on ne le
fait pas c'est des choix qui sont très
personnelles mais un homme public
c'est quand même compliqué à ce niveau
là d'aller dire respecter ma vie privée
c'est difficile est ce que vous avez dit
l'impression quand même que d'une façon
générale françois hollande a mal
anticipé les évolutions importés par le
quinquennat dans nos institutions dans
leur pratique je pense qu'un certain
nombre de choses qui effectivement il
n'a pas forcément vu venir la séparation
vie publique vie privée elle est devenue
une frontière très ténue pas forcément
quelque chose que il a compris à présent
la république ne s'appartient pas il
appartient au peuple français il doit
être protégé en permanence sa sécurité
d'où était de garantir en permanence je
suis pas sûr qu'ils aient toujours eu
conscience de cela
le quinquennat veut dire que les choses
vont très vite et que dès le premier
jour du quinquennat on doit être
efficace
on doit être utile pour les français or
qu'est-ce que monde cette conférence de
presse finalement c'est que françois
hollande n'était pas prêt et que c'est
les français qui en ont fait les frais
que pendant 18 mois
nous avons perdu du temps essayé de
solutions pu essayer une autre à
tergiverser à hésiter à reculer à dire
je fais ceci et puis je défais cela
souvenez-vous parce qu'on a la mémoire
courte du nombre de décisions que
françois hollande a pris au début de son
quinquennat qui ont été supprimés par la
suite ses propres décisions
que de temps perdu que de temps perdu
sur le dos des français bruno le maire
je voulais vous faire réagir à une
enquête parue hier du cevipof sur la
défiance envers les politiques qui
atteint maintenant des niveaux rouge
niveau hallucinant même a pu dire le
politologue pascal perrineau
à tel point que 50 % des pères des
personnes interrogées sont pour une
démocratie de type bonapartiste c'est à
dire un homme fort qui ne se préoccupe
ni du parlement ni des élections
est-ce que vous êtes prêts à être cet
homme là qui fait un homme fort ou une
femme forte
j'en suis totalement artistes et mon
inculpation mais parfois ça m'inspire
simplement que cette révolution
démocratique que j'appelle de mes voeux
et que certains critiques dans ma propre
famille politique est devenue une
urgence absolue
il faut changer les fonctionnement
institutionnel les fonctionnement
démocratique français quand j'étais tout
à l'heure aux questions d'actualité à
l'assemblée nationale 577 députés mais
mon dieu qu'est ce qu'on fait que 577
députés
on a augmenté le nombre de députés à
l'assemblée nationale dans le même temps
aux demandes et aux entreprises d'avoir
moins de salariés aux administrations
d'avoir moins de fonctionnaires au
service des comptes
entrez les plus efficaces mais c'est
inacceptable c'est intolérable
il est urgent que nous passions de 577 à
au maximum 400 députés consacrée
exclusivement la fonction de député et
rien d'autre comment est-ce qu'on peut
accepter dans notre démocratie dans
notre république qui devrait être
exemplaire au nom des idéaux de 1789 que
les hauts fonctionnaires puissent garder
tous leurs privilèges aux fonctionnaires
quand ils deviennent députés ou qu'il
devienne sénateurs le jour ils ont battu
pas de problème ils redeviennent
conseiller d'état inspecteur des
finances ambassades de là c'est
inacceptable c'est inacceptable donc oui
moi cette étude je n'ai lu avec beaucoup
d'attention
il ya urgence à réformer nos
institutions dans le champ de la
lisibilité de la simplicité de
l'efficacité pour que la décision
politique retrouve enfin du sens et
qu'elles changent réellement réellement
la vie quotidienne des français est ce
que cette recherche d'un homme fort par
les français interrogés ce que c'est bon
pour nicolas sarkozy par exemple
en tout cas c'est pas un homme faible
c'est une fille qui a du tempérament et
je pense à un besoin de tempérament
politique
on a besoin aujourd'hui de personnalités
qui s'engage avec sincérité pour le bien
public
pour exemple et qui est vraiment la
volonté de changer les choses de rentrer
enfin dans la modernité en ce qu'est la
société française moi ce que je constate
c'est que nous responsables politiques
nous avons des années de retard sur la
société française
nous sommes en décalage par rapport à
sur la pratique des nouveaux instruments
sur la pratique des nouveaux outils de
communication d'internet ou autre nous
avons du retard sur la conception la
société française nous avons dur qu'est
ce que vous allez faire comme nicolas
sarkozy va préciser ses intentions
moi j'y suis allé mais étiez candidat
putatif alors je n'ai jamais prononcé le
mot de candidats parce que je pense que
c'est un mot qui ne s'emploie qu'abonné
si l'on exclut et je poursuis mon chemin
avec une détermination totale à perdre
et de la nation total pour vous pour
vous voyez bien que je défends ton body
son original oui je défends centre de
propositions que ne défend pas tout le
monde au sein de l'ump
je les défendrai
termine à sion et les défendre à la
primaire à l'ump nous verrons quelle
forme cela prendra mais en général quand
je m'engage dans un chemin je ne recule
pas je parlais de manuel valls sur la
sphère dieudonné on l'accuse avoir agi
par pur calcul politique
alain juppé au contraire lui salue sa
conviction profonde à quelle est votre
opinion
je fais aucun procès d'intention à
manuel valls
ce qui compte pour moi ce sont les
résultats
je crois que la bonne méthode c'est de
sanctionner systématiquement les propos
antisémites ou racistes de dieudonné
il fallait mettre le holà et je me
félicite qu'on ait mis le holà à des
propos qui ne sont pas compatibles avec
la république maintenant je souhaite
aussi qu'on ne fasse pas de donner une
victime médiatique et donc simplement
que la loi passe et s'applique dieudonné
doit des dizaines de milliers d'euros au
trésor public qui les rembourse tout de
suite pour le citoyen comme vous comme
moi comme ceux qui nous écoutent qui ont
une amende à rembourser au titre de la
sécurité routière se joue comme une
infraction
vous pensez qu'on va les laisser
tranquilles on laissera jamais
tranquille vous avez vu cette histoire
de cette femme qui avait eu un trop
perçu comme on dit au titre des aides
sociales
elle vit avec 750 euros par mois on
irait terme de 1000 euros bas et
l'ambiance que dieudonné rembourse ont
vite et que le fisc soit efficace en la
matière a dit tout à l'heure que
l'interdiction du spectacle des données
doit rester une exception et donc du
coup également l'inversion la
jurisprudence par le conseil d'état doit
rester une exception
oui moi je reste sur la ligne que je
défends depuis le début même si la loi
laissant sa réplique
s'il y une déclaration antisémite ou des
propos racistes tenus par des données
n'osa de ses spectacles il doit être
sanctionné immédiatement cette sanction
doit être suivi d'effets c'est à dire
qu'il doit payer les amendes qu'il doit
et puis j'insiste aussi sur un point qui
me tient très à coeur
je crois qu'en matière d'éducation il
faut pas relâcher l'effort expliquer ce
qu'est la shoah ce que sont les actes
antisémites
à quoi ça a conduit ce que c'est que le
racisme à quoi ça conduit
systématiquement c'est un combat que la
république doit livrer jusqu'au bout
c'est d'autant plus important que l'on
voit que
mais dont il a repris son spectacle
dieudonné dans son théâtre parisien il
fait salle comble deux fois dans la même
soirée donc le public vient en masse et
applaudissent de quelqu'un une victime
médiatique
elle en profite toujours c'est pour ça
soyons fermes dans l'application de la
loi mais n'en faisons pas une victime
médiatique en interdisant
systématiquement ses spectacles merci
bono la mère d'avoir été avec nous ce
soir merci perrine tarneaud merci à tous
vents soirée a très vite
tendance est très nette elle est très
claire elle nous mène aujourd'hui à
l'ats